it's funny it's almost like Warner
Brothers is trying to win me back so I
want to talk about the news that jaw
sweetness apparently in talks to direct
Batgirl this is unexpected on a number
of fronts I think a lot of us had kind
of assumed that Joss Whedon was done
with the big-budget Hollywood system at
least for a little while um I mean it's
it's been a couple years since since age
of Ultron so there's that the last one
he worked with was Marvel and now he's
talking to the other side and another
major thing and I it's it's funny this
this whole conversation that he might
direct it which again I'm gonna
emphasize right now it's talks he's not
signed as yet at least not at the time
that I'm recording this so him being he
talks through this feels a little bit
like the Internet's desire made manifest
and I felt the same when Benedict
Cumberbatch was cast as Doctor Strange
it felt like almost the the collective
pleas of the internet almost seemed like
it made it a reality and this feels a
little bit like that too um this gives
me the opportunity to be kind of
positive and hopeful about DC movies and
that's nice I mean Joss Whedon in a lot
of ways feels like a very natural fit I
mean just given his very extensive work
in creating and working with strong
female characters from Buffy to River
Tam to his how he worked with Black
Widow and the Avengers movies he's just
it these very good at this he's always
been good at this and I think at this
point you know there's been a push
lately for directors who are more
reflective of the main characters when
it comes to these kind of Temple
materials so you know we have a woman
directing Wonder Woman and they got a
black director for black panther and so
forth I think Joss Whedon might be one
of the few people that most pop culture
folks will give a pass to rather than
insisting a woman direct Batgirl
so I mean this this is good I consider
this good even beyond just the idea of
him on this property being a good thing
I kind of want to expand the thought out
as to why this could be a
very good indication for a shift in
managerial tone from Warner Brothers and
I touched on this a little bit we talked
about Matt Reeves coming back to the
table actually signing to direct Batman
and that is that you look at Joss Whedon
and why he said he was done with Marvel
basically to the degree that Marvel was
insisting he integrates age of Ultron in
in incorporate and set up all the other
stuff it just burned the guy out and
exhausted him and and he was kind of
done with that so if he's coming to the
table and saying that you know maybe
I'll direct Batgirl in my mind part of
this conversation has to be you guys
need to give me the property and leave
me alone and let me do it and that's
generally not really what Warner
Brothers has been doing is they they did
that with Nolan and the Batman and his
Batman trilogy but other than that I
mean we know the absolute mess that was
all the interference and Suicide Squad
given how much was chopped out of BBS
and while there hasn't been it's clear
there is probably a pretty good
indication that that they got
heavy-handed in and dealing with the
post-production on that one as well so
if they can actually convince him then
then in my mind that must mean that they
are putting in some assurances and
probably even in the contract that he is
not going to be massively interfered
with and that he is going to be granted
some degree of autonomy to do what he
wants to do because I wouldn't imagine
he would he would even be in talks to do
it otherwise and if they're doing that
that's a shift and that's a shift from
the kind of micromanaging that's been
screwing everything up
and especially when I look at the bigger
scope of him being on this Matt Reeves
being on the Batman
Chris McKay being on Nightwing these are
guys that you don't just get to you know
to slot in a bit I mean they're not
Brett Ratner they're not the guys you
get in - just just shoot the script and
deliver the film they're guys with big
ideas in bigness and now to be fair so
is David Ayer that didn't save Suicide
Squad but at the same time I feel like
with the recent news of future projects
I still have my concerns for the
projects that have been in the works
under the
they happen doing things which means
water woman which means Justice League
which means Aquaman maybe but it seems
like looking further down the road
they're trying to realign not just like
in a we need to steer the whole universe
this way or that way cuz I mean that
that was that you know that wasn't
really gonna work so well but it seems
like they're adjusting the approach and
given my my railing against Warner
Brothers in their approach this is nice
and this is refreshing to see now again
it's still early he's not firmly signed
and there are a couple things that are
gonna I don't say causes for concern but
I'm kind of holding back and when you
see how they panic before I'm totally
dancing the street over this so like for
example right now Joss Whedon would
write direct and produce Wonder Woman
but there are no other producers from
within Warner Brothers itself currently
attached to this that to me is not a red
flag but that basically to me says
they're putting him in the position that
he was in when he pitched the Wonder
Woman to them you know years ago which
was basically like look put together you
pitch we leave to take it or we won't
nobody inside Warner Brothers itself has
put their skin in the game so that's one
thing and that's more of a you know that
it don't take it as a lock that this is
definitely gonna happen kind of thing so
there's that there's also the fact that
while this recent stuff has all been in
my mind pretty good news it's all been
Batman related so on the one hand that
makes sense Batman is the most lucrative
character that that DC has and is he's
the one with the strongest track record
in movies but at the same time I really
worry that they're kind of abandoning
the rest of the DC extended universe in
favor of more Batman now I'm in favor of
more Batman if it's good I mean I'm in
favor above anything coming from related
if it's good but at the same time you
know we've gotten Batman we've had good
and in multiple forms in animated and TV
and live-action and movies we've got
we've got good Batman up the but but
what we don't have is all these other
characters and these deeper cuts and
things like just as the dark which they
keep talking about but it's not moving
forward or are they so kind of being so
neat to the punch with the idea of an
r-rated superhero or lady thing if they
would just do Swamp Thing so the one
thing that does worry me in kind of a
broad sense is that I worry that they're
going to sacrifice the rest of the DCE
you in favor of buoying Batman because
from a strictly financial sense that's
what makes the most sense now that
having been said this is still not bad
news this is good news and I would
rather be getting good Batman material
than bad material with these other
characters I don't have an inherent
desire like I must see this character on
screen even if it's bad no I don't want
to see it if it's bad so if they can
realign sort of using restructuring and
Batman as like the solid pole in the
middle of it and you know that's the
Maypole and they dance around and
restructure around that I can work with
that
so I this doesn't change my position
that I still don't intend to see Wonder
Woman at this point I still don't tend
to see Justice League at this point
because those films were made under the
the umbrella and under the management
style that I have railed against them
that I hate but if they can keep making
the kinds of decisions that they're
making that they appear to be making now
with getting someone like Joss Whedon
with getting somebody like Matt Reeves
with getting somebody like Chris McKay
and if when production actually gets
going on any of these things they leave
them alone and just let them craft what
they have been hired to do I I could be
marijuana brothers side on this and I
haven't been for a while and that's kind
of crazy especially how hard I've rails
against them in the not-too-distant past
so you're headed in a good direction
Warner Brothers keep heading
there and I might just come along with
you so that's it guys surprisingly
positive thoughts on Warner Brothers
it's a nice change of pace isn't it in
any case what are your thoughts on this
particular development whatever they are
drops on the ground the comments so saga
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]